Berliners alivelu a--
and thomas bents are in the French
capital for the Preta potatoes they're
here to work but they found time to
enjoy a bit of Paris flare over a cup of
coffee
instead of a huffman he said when you
walk across the road you notice right
away that you're not in Berlin that's
especially true in areas like full
blokes on Honore or some German to pray
this is the capital of luxury women of
every age have fantastic hairdos the
older the secret and you see that a lot
less in Berlin after starting up and
this is where they're working the Berlin
showroom is making its second appearance
at Paris Fashion Week the project is
financed by the Berlin city government
and the EU a fashion industry jury
selects 23 designers to take part in it
his commanders know there's a fashion
week in Berlin but the Paris one is much
more International Journal he meets a
lot more buyers here than you do in
Berlin at some Cymbeline towards it's a
fantastic opportunity for the young
designers and their auckland label it
was clear to us from the beginning that
we had to make the leap to paris and
onto a more international stage than
berlin on the one hand because of the
product in our price category we have to
reach international customers but we
also have to gauge ourselves with the
others here and we can't shy away from
competition actually fine they put
together the new collection at their
berlin studio it's a young brand only
two years old they set it up when they
move to the German capital after years
in London Paulo value is the creative
mind of the duo
he studied fashion at the famous Central
Saint Martins school we were very
comfortable in Honda it was our home but
then we felt that to get the creative
process rolling we needed a little
friction and something new that's
annoying
their first collection came out in July
they're striking and richly contrasting
designs immediately earned them an award
at Berlin Fashion Week and accolades
from the press the sophisticated
creations certainly come at a price
this hand embroidered jacket costs 4,500
euros retail wow they're expensive
we used expensive skilled labor but the
fabrics are expensive too it's a
conscious decision we think it's
important to create something that has
lasting value a design which ideally
could become an heirloom something which
doesn't lose its relevance with a design
and greedy cat vineyard
their top of the line design sold twice
at the showroom many international
purchasers come here to look for new
designs this fire was looking for
dresses for her Istanbul boutique
fabrics are gorgeous they are very
beautifully skewed and just modern and
you know that's what people need
actually and she's really interested in
the idea of a Berlin showroom it's just
quite complicated when you go in a
showroom and see lots of designers from
different countries and it would it's
it's really nice to have the feeling of
the country actually what they are
feeling was the trend in the country
it's more daily German designers more
wearable
the Berlin showroom has given the two
up-and-coming designers a start in Paris
they both can imagine moving here
permanently in the future we're still
trying to figure out who responds best
to our designs I can't really say
whether we'll be based in London New
York or Paris in the long term
you never know what the future will
bring maybe in a few years time they'll
have a show of their own on the catwalks
of Paris Fashion Week